the hearing for the finance committee
and will then go into recess we have
some members running late we want to
make sure everybody arrives and gets to
vote on these six bills that we have
before us I don't think it's too
controversial some of the bills were
unanimous so out of the division so I
don't think we'll have a lot of
discussion so hopefully
we'll take a 30-minute recess to wait
for the arrival of of some of our
members that
either left early or left late or uh
told us they couldn't make it on time
so yeah right
so we are in recess I hope to return
about 10 30. thank you
the recess I'm told that representative
Bean is on his way
and we'll begin with the we have six
bills on the docket for today beginning
with division one I'll recognize
representative leishman
foreign
thanks Mr chairman and good morning I'd
just like to turn this over to
representative McGuire who will speak
briefly to the unanimous decision of the
division to retain the bill
thank you Mr chairman and Mr chairman
um so I'd like to move to retain Senate
bill 128.
okay so this is a bill
um that moves spending for
legal services for those who are
involuntarily committed
for mental care
from the spending is currently in the
health and human services department
this moves it to the judicial Council
and when when we heard the the testimony
on the bill
it was extremely lukewarm I would say
you know the the motivation for doing
this uh you know the sponsor didn't show
up the motivation for doing it was
somewhat unclear and uh representative
Griffin uh pointed out that it's
possible that as when this this item is
part of Health and Human Services that
there's matching funds available in that
under that venue but if it were moved to
judicial Council it's possible that
there would not be right it's likely
that there would not be in that case so
you know this could be a significant
cost increase for what seemed to us to
be
um
not really a strong benefit and so we
really want to make sure and no one from
Health and Human Services came to talk
to us so we really want to make sure
that that's not the case before we we
let this go so we we need more info
information and that's why we're
retaining them
further discussion
representative hole thank you Mr
chairman
so do those who are committed today have
access to Legal Services it's just
funded just for clarity right it's just
funded through DHHS instead
yes that's right yeah
and for those not familiar with judicial
Council we start off with very little in
their budget they come to fiscal for all
their their needs and they come almost
every meeting as as money is needed to
hire the uh Indigent Council and so on
so it'd be the same thing representative
Griffin
uh thank you Mr chair
we also heard from the judicial Council
and uh the estimated number of cases
here runs somewhere from 2200 to 2500
Plus
and the judicial Council right now
consists of three people
and they said they would be absolutely
overwhelmed
to take on the added caseload so that
was another major reason for retaining
the bill
further discussion
seeing none
the motion is to retain
Senate bill one two eight
see no further discussion
the clerk will call the roll on motion
to retain
thank you Mr chairman
um
representative Leon for representative
Burr yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney
yes
representative Edwards yes
representative uh
being is not here representative hole
yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Carol McGuire or yes
representative cameras
representative Mueller yes
representative Wallner
yes
representative yes
representative leishman yes
representative Buco yes
Arizona uh
representative grassy yes
okay representative Hewitt
yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes
representative evil yes
representative yes
representative hankin Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
and representative
Weiler yes
Mr chairman the vote is 24 to nothing in
the affirmative to return
the vote being 24-0 the bill will be
retained and no uh no Bill report is
required other than to have it listed as
retained all right we're again
recognized representative leishman
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
recognize representative McGuire that
will be offering an amendment 2080 for
the division
thank you Mr chairman yes I'd like to
move Amendment 2080h and I'll I'll speak
to my motion does this need a second
thank you
so Senate bill
um 204 is uh directs the state to put
trauma kits into state-owned buildings a
trauma kit is like a specialized first
aid kit that specifically designed to
um to help someone who is massively
bleeding bleeding very quickly so it it
contains two main elements one is a
tourniquet and one is what's called it
an Israeli compression bandage it's a
very large bandage that puts pressure on
a large wound and so
um
and the kit has a few other things but
that's the main thing it's it's for it's
for
use when when the EMTs are a little too
far away to to help someone who's who's
significantly bleeding and
um the the the amendment makes a few
improvements to the bill for one thing
the bill was originally specified
state-owned buildings but we have a lot
of buildings that are State occupied
particularly things like liquor stores
and other buildings that are leased and
those could benefit from having these
kind of kits as well so we added that
um the the
um the original Bill had a section that
was a little bit Overkill we felt it it
created a committee of EMTs to create a
list of buildings and so on but it turns
out the people that that normally deal
with facilities and buildings is the
Department of administrative services so
we changed the bill to have the
department of administrative Services
handle the distribution and the you know
purchasing and distribution of the kits
in can and let them consult with the
Emergency Services
um section of safety and then the the
final thing was the money
um the bill originally simply had a
dedicated fund that it could accept
gifts and grants but but it didn't
actually put any money in the fund so
therefore it wouldn't have acquired the
kits until such gifts and grants showed
up but the the amount of money here is
relatively small so we changed it so to
to eliminate the dedicated fund and to
allocate fifty thousand dollars for the
purpose that should get us somewhere
around 250 buildings
supplied and so if necessary to go from
there then future budgets could could
allocate more money for this
any questions on the amendment
representative hole
thank you Mr chair
um line 30 right section does not apply
to state-owned buildings that are is
vacant or under construction should that
be broader to than just vacant
um
for it we discussed earlier maybe things
like
um at the sununu center their storage
buildings is that under vacant
um how are we defining bacon I guess
yeah thank you for the question this is
a line that's unchanged from the the
amendment just for clarity is is a
replace all but this particular line is
unchanged from the original Bill and and
basically these kits are most useful
when there's a lot of people around
right so so places that are vacant or
otherwise rarely used uh you know it's
less useful
oh
representative Edwards and
representative Carol McGuire uh thank
you Mr chair uh I I have a few but I'll
just uh go at your leisure uh the
um
first thing I I'm curious about is this
is a very small list of medical items
that would be in there and it's mostly
stop the bleeding kinds of things are
there any of these components that have
an expiration date that they have a term
at which they need to be rotated and did
you give consideration for those on uh
who would be having unexpired items in
this kit and who would be responsible
for rotating the stock and how the old
stuff would get disposed was there any
thought about that
um yes thank you for the question
representative that did come up in our
committee and we learned that these have
a shelf life of of three to five years
some of the items in the kit are
one-time use only so like the tourniquet
for example once you use it you need a
new one
um but because this
uh this
requirement is sort of a new requirement
for das and their their Property
Services area this would be an ongoing
thing that they would have to they would
have to keep track of we didn't
explicitly put in the bill
you know obviously this is something
they would end up putting in their
budget right so when they need to
replace and and all that sort of thing
follow-up
um and then uh was there any estimate of
how many times this might have been
useful over the last 10 years in all
state buildings is there any consumption
rate uh assumption built into here
um no we did not we did not hear that
the only thing related to that that we
heard is that and this was from the EMTs
that that there were basically two sorts
of conditions that that happened that
the EMTs can't get there quick enough
one of them is this severe bleeding and
the other one is heart attacks and
that's why we have these aeds the
defibrillators right and so both of
those are starting to get spread through
the community in various ways but this
is uh we did not hear about specific
um you know cases or something you know
and and so was there discussion uh I
think with the aeds that comes with a
sort of an annual requirement for people
that become familiar with that equipment
uh it was there anything in this uh bill
or your amendment to require stop the
bleeding training
yes thank you for the question
um no there's there's requirement in
here specifically for instruction uh
material to be in the kit but there
isn't the requirement for training
all right thank thank you Mr chair I I
I'm gonna end up being the only person
voting no on this just just because of
my health care background in the Army I
I just don't see this as being practical
in terms of being able to implement it
and achieve the it's a great intent but
I just I just don't see it being
practical but thank you well some of
these things could go in rules or in a
bill next year
represent Carol McGuire thank you Mr
chair the the this bill went through my
committee first
we got an estimate that the first wave
of kits would cost something in the
vicinity of five to ten thousand dollars
depending on how much of a deal we could
get for buying them in quantity
and that it was
the cheapest and easiest way to prevent
the third major cause of death in New
Hampshire which is bleeding out so
we were informed that if you call 9-1-1
all of the dispatchers are fully trained
and how to use these kits so you don't
have to say well where's the
instructions what do I do now
it the use of these kits is also taught
in
CPR and first aid in other places so
it's not as rare as you might think and
so we thought that even if it prevented
one death
from a tragic accident someone coming in
and deciding to shoot up the DMV
or something like that we said okay this
this might prevent front to death at a
very cheap price
and it's something that the the
buildings can keep on hand it doesn't go
bad the expiration date on things like
latex gloves I mean that's
you could still use them after they've
expired I imagine it's not it's not as
critical as some other things that you
have to replace immediately
so that was why we were we thought it
was
getting an awful lot of bang for very
little amount of money
well we're glad you're here to add that
representative Griffin when the EMTs
were asked the question that uh
representative Edwards raised they said
the most important thing is if someone's
on the phone with 9-1-1
that this equipment be available because
the people on 9-1-1 are trained to tell
people over the phone how to use the
equipment
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman the availability of these
materials are definitely important I
have a friend who lost his leg in combat
and on his prosthetic he actually keeps
the trauma kit bungeed on so that if
somebody else is in a similar situation
he has the tools on board so having
these available for people should they
be needed is is I think a low-cost way
to provide necessary tools
further discussion on Amendment 2080
everyone has a copy
is a show of hand sufficient to adopt it
all those in favor of adopting Amendment
hands down anyone opposed it is
unanimous the motion before us now is
ought to pass as amended motioned by
representative McGuire second by
representative Griffin ought to pass as
amended on House Bill a correction
Senate Bill 204. the clerk will call the
roll
uh that's Dan McGuire or who who made
the motion uh Mr chair Dan McGuire
seconded by
representative Griffin very good
representative uh Leon yes
representative McGuire yeah
representative votes yes representative
Emrick yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards no
representative Bean yes
representative hole
yes
Arizona Sweeney yes president Carol
McGuire
representative Miller yes
representative Wallner
yes
representative norgren yes
representative leishman yes
representative Buco yes representative
uh grassy yes
representative Hewitt yes
representative Heath yes
return to Murray yes
representative evil yes
representative tolorski yes
yes
Arizona Stringham yes and representative
Weiler
there will not be a Minority Report
okay what do we do what happened here
2023-1
I'm sorry 24-1 my numbers are right I
just called it wrong
I recognize representative leishman for
Senate bill 267. thank you Mr chairman
I'd like to recognize representative
Abel to speak to the division's vote to
retain of seven to one
thank you very much Mr chairman um H SB
267 is a little bit complicated to
understand perhaps it helps if you um
know that it started out Life as a bill
that would have required Des to
um issue regulations on Advanced
recycling which you may remember that
process from last year that we passed in
conversations in the Senate it was
decided that perhaps what one should
look at is the cumulative
impact of a bill such that was say admit
emitting polluted air because the way
permitting works right now in permitting
by Des you're basically just looking at
what potential sources of pollution are
being emitted by that particular
facility being permitted as opposed to
the cumulative impacts of other
facilities in the area
so this bill
um which passed with a very very strong
vote on the house floor and 19-0 coming
out of Ena would have required the
commissioner of Des to consider a
cumulative impacts analysis in rules and
statutes and it would have authorized
the hiring of someone to sort of look at
existing rules and statutes and it was
going to authorize the a scoping study
and the ultimate idea was that the
analysis would recommend any rules and
potential legislation to require us to
look at cumulative impacts of any
facility that was permitted in
discussions in the division we talked a
little bit about what the word facility
meant in the in the bill we talked some
more about cumulative impacts and
overall we felt like we really needed to
look at it longer and so we decided to
retain the bill
who made the second I did McGuire thank
you further discussion on the bill
seeing none the motion is to retain
clerk will call a role on the motion to
retain on Senate bill 267.
thank you Mr chairman
representative delay on yes
version of David McGuire yes version of
Petri vocious
representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards
yes representative Bean yes
version of hole yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Carol McGuire yes
representative Mueller yes
representative waldor yes
representative norgren yes
Arizona Leachman yes
representative Buco yes representative
uh grassy no
yes
version of Heath yes
representative Murray yes
version of evil yes
representative
yes Phillips
there's gonna Stringham yes
Reverend weather
Mr chairman of old is 24 to 1.
ocean is uh the committee report is
adopted and we'll get a I'm sure you've
got the report written on no there is no
report required thank you
thank you
moving on to division three I'll
recognize and thank you very much
division one for your work moving on to
division three there is no division two
bills uh representative
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair I would
like to move OTP on Senate Bill 172 and
would could take a moment to speak to my
emotion say that number again I think
it's one it's listed as 182 but the real
number is 172. thank you for the correct
a rare typo second on 172.
and this is an amendment no it's it's an
actual bill
I sought to pass
OTP yes sir
okay continue wait a second
um for for those who have not looked at
this bill this is essentially uh
extending the eligibility for Aid to
families with dependent children and and
spending TANF money uh so that we can
support court-appointed Guardians when
they step in to fulfill uh the role of a
long list of people who are currently
eligible if you looked at line nine you
would see that current eligibility
extends to fathers mothers grandfathers
grandmothers brothers sisters
stepfathers stepmothers stepbrothers
stepsisters first cousins nephews or
niece uncles aunts and it adds court
appointed Guardian this seems to be a
very reasonable
extension of eligibility requirements
and I would recommend uh OTP yes
motion is ought to pass motion by
Edwards second by Mooney
on Senate bill 172.
further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question the clerk will call a role on
the motion of ought to pass on Senate
Bill 172. thank you Mr chairman
representative Leon yes
president McGuire yes president Petrie
volcise representative Emrick yes
Rosanna Griffin yes there's a Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes version of
being yes representative hole yes
representative Sweeney yes version of uh
Carol McGuire yes
representative popovichi Mueller yes
representative Waller yes
yes there's an organ
yesman yes
original bucco yes representative uh
grassy yes
representative Hewitt yes version of
Heath yes president Murray yes
version of evil yes
president representative haken Phillips
yes
yes there's a Stringham yes
representative Weiler yes yes Mr
chairman of vote is 25-0 in the
affirmative
thank you and representative Edwards
have you had a report written uh that'll
be easy to do I'll have it before I
leave thank you
unless representative Mooney already has
one
[Laughter]
moving on
uh Mr chair I'd like to move SB 239 to
retain and they'd like to speak to my
motion second
Edwards moves Mooney seconds that Senate
Bill 239 be retained
uh thank you thank you Mr chair uh this
is um this is a friendly retention
effort
um I've reached out to Senator Waters
who came in and testified on this bill
um and I've talked to a few other people
this this bill uh does a a couple of
new things or three three new things
that cause some concern
um and and and an interest in more
Precision the first thing it does uh
from my perspective that causes concern
is on page four uh lines 20 21 and 22
where we have had a Prohibition in our
current law
Mr chair
say again oh should I stop or you no
he's just getting sorry to interrupt no
no no I'm I I just want to follow your
lead so
um what this does is in the current law
we have had a the prohibition on using
State money to pay for needle exchanges
so so there have been some exception
cases where we've specifically
authorized State money for needle
exchanges but this would get rid of sort
of the blanket uh prohibition on use of
State money and and I uh I I think we
want to take a deeper look at that and
see what the implications of of having
State money spent in that manner would
be uh my instinct says it's not good but
there there will be a committee put
together small work group
led by
um I've asked Dr David Nagel who's a
national expert on opioid
reduction in harm reduction to have him
come in and basically take the
intellectual lead on this there are a
few other people waiting for Senator
Waters to come in and nominate somebody
the other two things it does is it um
introduces kind of A New Concept in New
Hampshire Law related to reduction or
harm reduction rather and this is a
poorly defined term that got fixed a
little bit in HHS before it went to the
house but talking to some folks who
participated in that process they're
still not comfortable that we've got the
harm reduction right and and just as a
kind of a personal story I I I think
we're about 10 to 15 years behind Europe
on the harm reduction efforts
um I you know I used to travel to
Amsterdam a lot and they decided to
follow a harm reduction program and the
town of Amsterdam and key tourists areas
just became profligate with open-air use
of of drugs and narcotics even though
they were trying to go a harm reduction
route so I just want to make sure that
this subgroup really makes sure that the
definition and boundaries on what harm
reduction truly means is defined because
in San Francisco it includes
safe injection sites where people can go
and get illicit drugs injected into them
and I don't think that's consistent with
New Hampshire culture so but we'll look
at that and then the third thing it does
is it imposes a minimal uh requirement
on new training for all licenses related
to controlled prescription health and
safety programs I'd like to see that in
context you know what how much training
are they already being mandated to take
and and what is the impact of requiring
three more hours and is three the right
number should it be one or two or
something else so so I think there's
some real work this is like I said this
is all friendly you know the idea of
having less harm done in our society is
a good one I think we can all subscribe
to but I really would recommend that we
look before we leap and I know this is
going to be a tight vote but I would ask
for your yes vote on the retained motion
thank you further discussion
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for that great breakdown of some of the
challenges with the current structure of
this bill
um in Health and Human Services we did
do a lot of work in order to try and
refine the definition of harm reduction
and it's absolutely critical to make
sure that we get that right there was
some great work done to make sure that
people at end of life or with chronic
pain were not wrapped up in some of the
drug use mitigation efforts because for
some people opiates are the correct
choice and truly the reducing harm is by
making sure that they have appropriate
access just as we worked through it
there were a lot of challenges that
conceptually Health and Human Services
knew that this was a good idea to start
working towards but financially we need
to make sure that we understand the
consequences because harm reduction has
been drawn very very broadly in other
states we did a good first effort in
defining it here but before we open up
more funding and more State funding we
need to make sure that our other harm
reduction efforts that we sent over such
as the the drug checking to make sure
that people who are using Straight
Street drugs can make sure that the
Cannabis they purchase isn't laced with
fentanyl where a woman in my district
has now lost her son that we make sure
our entire harm reduction efforts come
together to make sure that not only
state-funded harm reduction but those
are people taking initiative are
embraced is absolutely critical because
harm reduction isn't just one approach
this is why we're working so hard on the
definition and we need to enable people
all throughout the state to reduce harm
so thank you I'd support a retained
motion
representative Stringham uh thank you Mr
chairman SB 239 was a highly supported
bill by in the house after a lengthy
floor discussion led by Dr Nagel the
bill passed overwhelmingly
there are no Financial Appropriations in
this bill therefore any reasons for
retaining the bill related to policy not
financing at this point the floor debate
was very persuasive the vote of the
house clear and no Financial impact I'm
going to vote against the motion to
retain and I urge you all to join me
uh and but thank you for the opportunity
to speak
further discussion representative
tolerski thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to make one clarification at the
hearing with the senator who's the Prime
sponsor he was asked directly would this
bill fund safe infections injection
sites and the answer was no absolutely
not this bill does not support safe
injection sites it is not in the bill is
allowable so I just wanted to clarify
that I will be joining my colleague
voting against this I believe this bill
will actually save lives and I think
it's unfortunate that it potentially
could be held until next year
further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question the clerk will call a role on
the motion to retain
on Senate Bill 239
thank you Mr chairman
representative Leon yes
representative McGuire yes
Reginald Petrie votes yes representative
Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative uh Bean yes
president of hole yes
president Sweeney yes president Carol
McGuire
there's a popovichi Mueller yes
Representative walner no
version of norgren no
Representative leishman no
representative Buco no no representative
grassy no
representative Hewitt no
General Heath no
Murray no
version of evil no
Representative no
representative Phillips no
representative Stringham no
original y there
yes
Mr chairman the vote is 13 to 12.
motion is adopted
moving on to Senate Bill 263
representative Edwards uh I would like
to move that we retain SB 263 and I'd
like to speak to that motion
second
thank you
foreign
thank you Mr chair
um so as a member of the commission that
looked at the granite state Advantage
Program
in uh I'm already in record on that
report as approving the
um the granite Advantage Health Care
Program and its extension uh I I would I
would just like to point out that we
that report did not specify a length of
time at which the for which the program
should be repealed or extended so it was
silent on that and so there has been
some a lot of discussion on it the
initial house position was two the
initial Senate position was forever
current bill before us essentially says
forever we we put this item into hb2 so
that it could be a better discussion
just it's uh it's my understanding
that there's a rapidly developing
consensus around a sunset of six or
seven years I'll I I won't I won't put
my thumb on that too much but
um the uh so there is no doubt we want
to take this to another five-year
contract and that's how we get to six or
seven if you if you recognize that we
need one year to get to the new contract
and that every contract in Medicaid
wants to be a five-year contract that's
six so the argument for the seventh year
is is I think a rational one where it
would be good to be able to add the
option and the contract of extending it
for one more year just in case we have
some
turbulence towards the end of the
contract where the legislature needs to
be more clear so so so why bother with
the sunset you all have heard this
before
um uh we we know that the legislation
that's already in fact in effect says
that if the federal government backs off
of its current ninety percent uh match
level that that gives us the potential
to
get out of the program but the current
law does not talk about changes in
eligibility so uh it it so if the
federal government who I don't think we
have any business trusting to keep their
promises uh changes something I think
it's an incumbent upon us today and and
with this legislature to give us a
future legislature a graceful way out if
this is a good program if the feds uh
you know surprise us and keep their
promises then I suspect this program
will be easily extended and if not it
can be easily uh exited so so the motion
is basically let's retain 263 and let
the hb2 item be worked out between the
president of the Senate and the speaker
of the house if I were to bet I would
bet that they would agree on either six
or seven years which ought to give us
all confidence that we're going to be
taking care of the health care needs of
New Hampshire
further discussion representative
Stringham
thank you Mr chairman as SB 263 passed
in the house by a wide margin and
unanimously in the Senate 24-0
it provides for permanently
reauthorization of the widely supported
Granite Advantage Program which sunsets
December 31st 2023 by current law
retaining the bill won't help us if we
bring it back here after January 1st
when the program is expired
the retention of the bill is principally
in favor of the budget house B2
program extension which currently is two
years in our view the non-arbitrary
calendar triggers in the existing bill
that Safeguard future budgets are
adequate
and adding another calendar
trigger is not necessary and in fact
could be harmful to the program itself
and create inefficiencies during any
reauthorization or recontracting that
may come up we'll have plenty of
opportunities to challenge the program
modify the program if the federal
government changes his mind without a
calendar trigger
therefore
um I think we should continue uh to make
our our intent known of keeping this
program in place which is serving our
constituents so well there's nothing
graceful about a time trigger two years
from now six years from now or seven
years from now for so for these Reasons
I'm going to vote against this motion to
retain so a better motion could be
brought forward
further discussion
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman in all the
discussion on this bill that we had on
the house floor and and here today
it's been talked about as as a great you
know program and and strong and so on
and
um but there is a downside to this
um and I'd like to at least mention it
this program has very poor incentives
the structure of it is all wrong from my
point of view
I'm a part owner of a restaurant
and our experience in the restaurant was
that in the old days when we wanted
people to work extra hours they were
very willing to do so right they wanted
to earn more money and so on
but today even though we have roughly
the same number of employees that we had
prior to the pandemic
we they are working many many fewer
hours because they're well aware that
that programs like this have a cliff and
if they work too much they they lose
their eligibility for this kind of a
program and so therefore when we ask
people please can you work you know an
extra evening or an extra whatever they
say no I can't because all of a sudden I
would lose this particular benefit and
so there this program you know is well
intentioned but I think it needs if
possible to be restructured in such a
way that there's not a cliff but a but a
ramp
um so that so that
um people it doesn't disincentivize work
we are no longer able to we used to be
open for lunch and dinner every day now
we are only open for lunch a few days a
week because we simply can't get enough
people to work it's that simple thank
you Mr chair
further discussion representative
Edwards uh uh thank you Mr chair and and
thank you for for your remarks and your
observation uh I I didn't mention in my
intro but
um uh I I sort of feel accountable as
maybe all of us should that while the
granite state Advantage program has been
in place there hasn't been an effort to
go and work through the details of what
an alternative ought to look like and um
and so this was a a major
observation on my part of a little Dam
how come we haven't been working on
something that's better than this and um
and we just didn't so so my commitment
to you would be if I'm still around in
eight years that you can feel the
shutter run through the room but if I'm
that I I will have tried to get the
smart people like you and others
together to figure out what the future
might look like so that when this bill
is coming towards termination maybe
before then that we show up with
something and and my sort of attitude is
you can't beat something with nothing
and this is something and we don't have
anything so so I I think there's some
work to be done and I hope hopefully we
can talk about that
foreign
thank you Mr chairman looking back to
our last session
um there had been a very good
effort in order to try and discuss some
of the challenges around the program and
why it's important to have a sunset but
unfortunately a lot of those discussions
were not permitted this program provides
a very valuable benefit for people
however if we were to move to a
permanent extension with no Sunset that
would continue to shift the whole
landscape in this country around Health
Care as it stands there are a few States
who have not adopted expanded medicaid
at all and when you look to the National
level I'm with National Council Of State
legislatures on some of the health care
policy teams and when there's a shift
and if all of the states are on board
there will be more shifts in the
Medicaid expansion World in DC because
we're moving to a much more controlled
Health Care system and when those
holdouts move to Medicaid expansion
they're going to be more ships in the
Health Care system as more and more
States ex have permanent Medicaid
expansion that further shifts the
discussion on a national level by having
reauthorization pair periodically here
in New Hampshire we have a better check
on what happens in Washington DC
regardless of who is in power there one
party or the other there's always going
to be changes that may not be a benefit
to the people of New Hampshire so
needing to reauthorize it is absolutely
critical that's one of those areas that
helps to keep our cost under containment
by having these discussions and I think
that it's very important that we retain
it this is this language is in the
budget I fully support the efforts that
are moving forward on the budget and I I
believe we will come to a good
compromise for the people of New
Hampshire and this program will continue
I think that a vote to retain this is a
vote of confidence in US passing a
budget in the house because assuming we
pass a budget this is unnecessary
because it's already going to be
continued for the people of New
Hampshire and I quite honestly think
that saying that this bill needs to
continue so that we don't meet the the
cliff is a vote of no confidence in the
budget and I I was really hoping we
could continue this bipartisan effort to
work for the people of New Hampshire and
bring the solutions that they're asking
for forward so I'll be voting to retain
thank you further discussion
representative
thank you Mr chairman Miller
um I just wanted to very quickly uh
comment on an earlier statement made by
distinguished colleague that said that
the bill had broad support it was
broadly supported
I didn't want to just let my
recollection and I checked the results
and the
OTP motion had 189 votes from the
Democrats four from the Republicans out
the 400 people
I think it's important when we use broad
support to maybe at least wait until it
gets over 200 out of 400 before we call
it that so it was a narrow vote and the
house had every right to vote that way
and I see the results but I don't
consider that a broad mandate from the
house thank you
for the discussion on the motion to
retain Senate Bill 263 FM representative
Hewitt
Mr chairman I'm also going to vote in
opposition to
this bill
talking about when the people when it
will work harder if they if you put a
work requirement in
the reason I think that in most cases at
least today when it comes to Health Care
that the reason that people are
unwilling to work a lot of extra hours
is that the remuneration for working the
extra hours isn't sufficient to make up
the difference between what they're
going to get in benefits if they get
sick
that as they would get if they're well
and that's a really concern for people
particularly because people with small
children and people with small children
are people who are frequently involved
in the business of a work requirement
um
the
the other thing that concerns me is that
we're putting we're putting a time limit
on it the time limit right now the
deadline is December 31st this year
ain't talking about how many years out
it is or not uh the the statute that's
in effect now
expires on December 31st and whatever
position you take on any other aspect of
the bill uh legally that's a really
important deadline to consider because
you don't you don't have the you don't
have the luxury of retaining and just
retaining and doing going from one thing
to the other in order to change things
without
bearing that firmly in mind
and
furthermore
um if you if you put a drop dead
provision then such as the the one
that's being proposed uh in connection
with the with the the
discussion of the Republicans have been
having had
it's simply another way of saying well
we're gonna we're gonna end this thing
without having to do anything
uh you don't have to you don't have to
find that there's anything wrong with it
in order to uh in order to stop it if
you have a deadline
uh as far as I can see there isn't any
big push right at the moment for saying
that the Medicare Medicaid Advantage is
a bad thing in fact uh the experience
around the country is kind of quite the
opposite so I'm I'm going to uh I'm
going to vote
in in my conscience to make sure that
this this
um the the Medicaid expansion continues
and is available to people but so long
as it does a job that does not does not
require people to vote it down thank you
um thank you Mr chairman and I think the
previous representative speaking for his
remarks um I think that there's a lot of
confusion about what Medicaid expansion
actually is if you are somebody with
young children you are not actually
eligible for Medicaid expansion because
you are on traditional Medicaid when we
had received different feedback we would
received feedback from people in the in
the disability Community however people
on disability are on traditional
Medicaid not Medicaid expansion this is
yet one more example about how
misunderstood this program is and how it
requires the the ongoing review of the
legislature to make sure that we
continue to do things right for the
people of the state because we do things
the New Hampshire way not the D.C way
further discussion on the motion to
retain Senate bill 263.
representative Stringham I thank my
colleagues for their comments and
Medicaid expansion uh uh has done a a
lot for uh closing the contract between
those who are doing everything they can
uh to take care of themselves and be
productive members of society but not be
shut out of the Health Care Marketplace
I totally agree with comments uh buyer
division chair and representative
McGuire that we can make this program
better I still don't think having a
calendar-based trigger does anything to
do that I think we should do that by
taking our The Limited energies that we
have to do things by uh talking and
putting together bills that make make
this program even more effective and not
retaining this Bill thank you
further discussion on the motion to
retain Senate bill 263.
seeing Nani ready for the question clerk
will call a role on the motion to retain
thank you Mr chairman
representative Leon yes
representative McGuire yes
representative
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes
represent a Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
there's a hole yes
representative Sweeney yes
version of Carol McGuire yes
there's a pop of each Mauler yes
representative Wallner
no
Representative no
Representative leishman no
Rosanna Buco no
version of grassy no
representative Hewitt no
representative Heath no
representative Murray no
representative evil no
real generator no
representative hicken Phillips no
string them no
representative Wilder
yes
Mr chairman a vote is 13 to 12 in favor
of the motion
the motion 13 to 12 the report will be
to retain for Senate bill 263.
I guess that's not going on concerned
the next uh meeting is June 8th on
Thursday
is there anyone that won't be able to
attend that we know of now
okay
um this
that's the session
the session will be next Thursday June
8th so so Mr chair question yes do you
think these motions will be heard and
voted on in the next session
I think we're making the uh
the calendar that could go in there but
it's still it's up to the speaker and
the clerk what goes on there
uh thank you Mr chair
so it's possible
um anything else to come before this
committee
seeing none I thank you for your
attendance and go out and enjoy this
beautiful day we are adjourned